es geht in der These darum dass durch
entzündliche Prozesse im Gehirn die nach
einer covid 19 Infektion noch auftreten
können eben auch man sieht dass Menschen
unter gehirnnebel leiden können dass sie
ein fatig-syndrom bekommen können das
heißt antriebslos werden
eine riesige Schläfrigkeit mit sich
rumtragen die auch durch längere Pausen
nicht verbessert wird sind kurzatmig
haben häufiger Schmerzen und eins der
Probleme die diese entzündlichen
Prozesse im Gehirn mit sich bringen ist
dass auch langfristig das ein
Risikofaktor dafür ist an Alzheimer zu
erkranken im übrigen auch das haben wir
eben mal kurz angesprochen auch
ungewollte Einsamkeit ist hier ein
Risiko sich weniger zu bewegen ist ein
weiteres Risiko aber eben entzündliche
Prozesse im Gehirn sind auch ein Risiko
und auch wenn die Chance an long kovic
zu erkranken niedrig ist also die
meisten Studien finden hier fünf bis
zehn Prozent aller infizierten das heißt
aber auch dass neun von zehn das nicht
bekommen insofern geht es mir nicht
darum die Panik zu machen jetzt zu sagen
jetzt müssen wir die nächste Krise
sozusagen im Gesundheitssystem erwarten
aber wir müssen aufpassen wir haben
schon jetzt riesige Ausfälle in
Krankenhäusern auch in anderen
infrastruktureinheiten durch Menschen
die in ihrem Konzentrationsvermögen in
ihrem
gedächtnisfähigkeiten eingeschränkt sind
zumindest für viele Monate und diese
Patienten muss man ernst nehmen und auch
da bin ich dabei was Herr Schubert eben
gesagt hat wir müssen über unseren
Medizinsystem nachdenken dass wir hier
in dem Sinne ganzheitlicher behandeln
müssen ist wir brauchen Teams von Ärzten
die halt diese verschiedenen Symptome
behandeln es reicht nicht dass wir den
Spezialisten für einen Organ haben weil
dann haben wir bei Krankheiten die was
mit Autoimmunität zu tun haben die
psychische Faktoren betreffen die nicht
eindeutig identifizierbar an einem
klassischen Fach der Medizin fest zu
machen sind ein ein Problem hier müssen
wir auch in der Ausbildung anders mit
den Medizin jungen Medizinern umgehen
und vor allen Dingen müssen wir glaube
ich jetzt lernen den Patienten auch als
mündigen Bürger zu betrachten den ganz
viele der Patienten vor allen Dingen
Patientinnen zwei Drittel davon sind
Frauen wurden wieder abgewiesen und
gesagt ja ja sie haben jetzt so ein
bisschen über Angststörung das kriegen
wir schon wieder in Griff und man hat
nicht die Symptome ernst genommen weil
man nicht den eindeutigen auf einem
Teststreifen feststellen machen
Biomarker hatte und ich glaube auch das
müssen wir ändern wir müssen hier die
Patienten Patientin ernster nehmen wie
kann long Kove zweifelsfrei heute
festgestellt werden Zweifelsfall kann es
nicht festgestellt werden weil ein Teil
der Symptome eben auch wir haben es eben
mal gehört können auch
Begleiterscheinungen von Einsamkeit sein
können Begleiterscheinungen vom
mangelnder Bewegung sein können
begleitentscheinungen von Stress sein
bei den Patienten wo man hat nachschauen
können hat man festgestellt dass
bestimmte Faktoren also eins ist ein
Stressfaktor der aber nicht nach oben
sondern nach unten geht dass das cortis
das war ganz überraschend das zeigt dass
das keine reine Stressreaktion ist und
es gibt bestimmte Signalmoleküle des
Immunsystems die haben unseren fachnamen
Interleukine da kann man dann immer so
einen eigenen Sprachkurs machen
entscheiden das ist ein Signalstoff der
das Immunsystem antreibt und da hat man
gefunden dass bei den Patienten wo man
hat nachgeschaut dass erhöht ist aber es
fehlen jetzt große klinische Studien um
hier das Spektrum etwas genauer
abzudecken es wäre aber für die
Patienten ganz ganz wichtig ich meine
die haben ihre Symptome auch ohne
Biomarker deren Marker ist ihre
kognitive Eingeschränktheit ihre
schnelle Schlappheit aber es würde
helfen eine Behandlung
es fehlt an Daten und an Studien die
eben jetzt auch sagen wie wie kann ich
helfen wann mache ich welche behandeln
das ist ganz unterschiedlich die mache
ich eine kognitive Therapie mache ich
eine Physiotherapie bei Menschen mit
einem fatig-syndrom bin ich ganz
vorsichtig weil wenn man die kurzfristig
überlastet erleben die einen riesigen
Rückfall haben Menschen sich eine
Kurzatmigkeit angewöhnt das ist jetzt
gar nicht dass der Virus noch da ist der
Virus was gemacht hat sondern war mit
der Atmung vorsichtiger und hat nicht
tief genug ins Zwerchfell eingeatmet die
brauchen Atemtraining da gibt es auch
welche die genug Geld haben haben sie
von Opernsängern trainieren lassen das
muss man nicht sondern man kann ganz
normale Atemübungen machen es gibt auch
Menschen die unter geruchsverlust leiden
da kann man geruchstraining machen es
gibt viele verschiedene mögliche Dinge
die man machen kann um das in den Griff
zu kriegen aber wichtig gerade für die
Patienten die ich sag mal in ihrem
denkleiden ihrer Denkleistung ihrem
Konzentrationsvermögen das damals zu
hören doch Leute das ist jetzt keine
Einbildung das habe ich wirklich
Herr Schubert Alzheimer durch Corona
also ich freue mich dass wir so langsam
uns annähern heute
und wenn sie sagen wir brauchen
interdisionäre Teams dann kommen wir
schon näher ich warne nur noch einmal
oder würde mich sehr freuen vielleicht
lasse es waren mal weg und komme mal in
die konstruktive Seite hinein und und
und vielleicht ist das wirklich die
große Chance das lonko wird dass die
Psychosomatik jetzt gesehen wird endlich
gesehen wird nach so vielen
Jahrhunderten innerhalb der Medizin dass
die Ganzheitsmedizin einen Aufschwung
bekommt für mich ist Corona ein Turbo in
unserer Gesellschaft in unserer Kultur
in unserer Ideologie in unserer falschen
Medizin Ideologie es hat unglaublich es
ist unglaublich viel falsch gelaufen den
letzten drei Jahren weil die Medizin so
ist wie sie ist und wir haben jetzt die
große Chance etwas zu verändern und
konnte das gerade angesprochen und ich
plädiere massivst ich bin auch den
interfusionären Teams etwas kritisch
gegenüber weil ich kenne die Macht der
Biomedizin ich kenne die Macht der
Schulmedizin und ich weiß wie Teil des
psychische dann wieder zum Epiphänomen
wird von körperliche Aktivität warum
wird Biomedizin von Schulmedizinern
eigentlich immer gesagt das ist quatsch
das bringt nichts das Medizin ist
Schulmedizin das ist für mich der
Begriff nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein das ist für mich der
Begriff Biomedizin und mir ist wichtig
wie gesagt also psychosomatisch an diese
Patienten Herangehen an die Geschichten
dieser Menschen wir wissen zum Beispiel
longkowitsch das ist doch ganz schön
viele gibt die schon Vorerkrankungen aus
dem psychischen Spektrum haben wir
wissen das von den posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörungen ja auch also sind
enorm viel Überlappungen zwischen diesen
Krankheitsbildern Corona hat gezeigt die
corona-pandemie das ist da ist das ist
da ist und wie gesagt also eine
posttraumatische Belastungsstörung zeigt
sich genauso wenn sie nicht durch ein
dezidiertes Trauma hervorgerufen wurde
aufpassen dann gibt es diese ganzen
schlaflosigkeiten und und Albträume und
und und wieder Erinnerungen an die
Traumatisierung in diesem Fall ist ein
diffuses Trauma es sind die ein Trauma
das durchaus von Politik und Medizin
gesetzt wurde in Angst und Panik an
Lauterbach hat nie aufgehört zu
traumatisieren und ich denke wir
brauchen uns nicht wundern wenn solche
Krankheiten dann Auftreten der Mensch
ist sensibel ist eine zarte eine zarte
Seele ja und wenn man auf der rumtrampe
drei Jahre lang so wie das jetzt
passiert ist dann wundere ich mich nicht
über diese postomatischen
Belastungsstörungen nochmal ich auch das
ist vielleicht da sind wir vielleicht
unterschiedlich hier aber ich bin und
setzt das hier hin ich mache hier einen
Punkt das ist für mich eine PTSD das
longkowith und es wird die Zukunft
zeigen es wird noch viel Untersuchungen
brauchen aber die Überlappungen sind so
deutlich und auch Psyche macht was mit
autoimmun wir wissen dass
Autoimmunerkrankungen je mehr wir gucken
desto mehr sehen wir das Trauma ein
großer Aspekt ist bei
Autoimmunerkrankungen wir kennen Burnout
hat auch ist auch ein stressostizierte
Erkrankung
somatoforme Störungen dieser ganze große
Bereich der wächst jetzt zusammen und
longkobiker für mich total dazu ich
würde gerne den Themenblock Corona für
heute abschließend noch einer Frage an
Sie Akkorde wenn Zuschauer das Gefühl
hat ich habe auch das Gefühl ich leide
unter long koved wo kann man sich
hinwenden was kann man tun wie kann man
praktisch dagegen vorgehen oder sich
Hilfe holen entscheidend ist dass man
sich ärztlichen Rat holt dass man nicht
selber therapiert einige meinen sie
müssten Nahrungsergänzungsmittel nehmen
um das Immunsystem zu stärken und machen
sich gerade dann nicht so klar dass
Immunsystem zu unspezifisch zu stärken
ist gar nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
was man ja meint ist es besser
einzuregulieren also das wichtigste ist
eben hier mit Ärzten zusammen ihr eine
einen Weg zu finden was sind die
Symptome was sind die möglichen Ursachen
und auch eine Autoimmunerkrankung egal
wie sie ausgelöst wurde lässt sich
behandeln zum Teil auch mit kognitiven
Therapien aber eben auch mit
Medikamenten die versuchen das
Immunsystem wieder einzufangen oft auch
mit beiden also das sind keine
ausschließenden Verfahren die man hier
einsetzen sollte also wichtig ist sich
da oder sich eben zu informieren und zu
helfen und vor allen Dingen ist aber
auch wichtig und das gilt nicht nur für
die betroffen sind sondern es gilt auch
für den Bekanntenkreis diese Menschen
ernst zu nehmen in sie ihren Symptomen
egal worin die begründet sind dass man
sich das anhört dass man den mit Rat und
teils zur Seite Schild steht und wir
haben es eben gehört Menschen in
Gemeinschaften sind deutlich resilienter
sind deutlich widerstandsfähiger gegen
Einschläge im gesundheitlichen Bereich
also von daher Ihre Frage würde ich ein
bisschen unmünzen was kann der Einzelne
tun ich glaube wir können alle viel tun
und das heißt jetzt auch Gemeinschaften
wieder zu stärken